the doctor and the boyfriend here we go
again the caretaker this is probably the
episode of the new series that I'm the
most simple about it it's not bad I
don't want to give that impression but
I've got the most mixed feelings about
out of anything so far largely just
because what is dealing with is an
aspect of current version of Doctor Who
that I really don't care for and never
have I call it the domestics because
that's what the doctor himself is called
and I'm talking about the things that
tie a companion back to the real world
so parents siblings friends boyfriends
whatever it's something that the show
never dealt with in the classic era and
in that regard is one of the things that
I prefer the classic eras approach
because when the new show first started
dealing with that it was kind of
interesting because why as I said
classic era number did it but for me it
got old really quick and they just keep
doing it again and again and again
Rosa's family Martha's family Donna's
family
Amy drags along Rory Clara got double
dipped for her own family and the family
that she was watching the kids for it's
just never an aspect I found
particularly interesting and here we go
again as Clara gets in deeper with her
relationship with Danny and obviously
that conflicts with her life on the
TARDIS with the doctor that said it
wasn't terrible I wasn't in pain it's
one of those things were like okay if we
have to do this this is about as well as
it's gonna get done largely because I
still like the character of Danny pink
himself and that does take the curse off
it a bit I like him as a character unto
himself I like his interactions with
Clara I actually ended up really liking
his interactions with the doctor which I
wasn't sure I was gonna like because
they've gone very heavy-handed with sort
of setting up what the two of them
meeting is gonna be like and by that I'm
referring to all the stuff that's gone
on in episodes up to this point
referring repeatedly to the fact that
the doctor doesn't like soldiers now
here's the thing if you've been watching
the show really ever you should kind of
know that already and even if you don't
just one or two reminders is enough but
this current series has really just been
hammering that point over and over again
it's like okay fine we get it and it was
so obvious why they were doing it to set
up for when he inevitably runs into
Danny that there was going to
that tension in that conflict but the
thing is those two characters butt heads
naturally enough that it didn't need
this big setup and that's sort of the
other thing that takes the curse off it
as ham-fisted as the set up before the
conflict was you get the two of them in
a room together I like the way the
interact I like the way they bounce off
each other I like the way they challenge
each other another thing that I I'm
surprised that I liked is the fact that
these sort of sci-fi more classic Doctor
Who aspect of the story is really kind
of sidelined its background for the most
part and normally that would annoy me
but they've they've scaled the story
such that it works very well it's a such
a simple straightforward story that
there would have been no point in
spending the entire episode on it it's
too simple but as the through line as
something to keep the doctor doing and
keep him busy it works very well Peter
Capaldi is still doing great work he
also has some interesting things with
with one of the students at the school
that he's pretending to be the caretaker
at and I like that enough that I'm
actually kind of torn as to whether I
want to see them do anything more with
that or not I liked what went on I'd be
interested in seeing again but then
again as a one-off it felt it felt like
a completed moment it didn't feel like
something worth revisiting and oddly I
actually liked Clara quite a bit I feel
like we got a better definition on her
in this episode then we've had really
since ever I think partially because the
question actually got asked point-blank
why does she travel with the doctor and
the thing is I've never really
understood that myself and I think that
might be part of why I've never gotten
on board with her all the other
companions I've understood why they were
there why they chose to go in the first
place and why they chose to stay for as
long as they did Clara no she just kind
of turned up and then stuck around seems
like she doesn't seem impressed with
anything that's going on she doesn't
seem particularly emotionally invested
in what's going on she's just she's just
there so it was kind of nice to have
that question asked point-blank and it
just sort of reassured me oh oh I'm not
the only one who's wondering thank you
so like it's a pretty good episode as
far as these sort of more earth-based
dealing with the domestic side episodes
go it was one of the better ones
certainly I am nervous as to where
they're gonna go with Danny after this
episode whether or not I
completely on board with and really
hinges on what they choose to do with
him because I like him as a character
but there are certain things that they
may choose to do with them that I would
rather they didn't so I'm gonna have to
wait for the next few episodes to see
what direction I actually go with but I
think that's about it for me on this one
now let me ask you this
who was your favorite character who was
rooted in the domestic side of things
and I'm talking about characters like
Jackie Mickey
Clara's grin for me personally and if
you've seen my companion rankings you
know this for me it's Wilfred Maud he
was the pinnacle of how good this stuff
can be but he's the minority most of
them bugged me but who was your favorite
character on that whole domestic front
whoever it was drop something down in
the comments and let's talk about it
until next time this council is
adjourned